[Music]
let's talk about this game stop i'll
break it down real quickly this is real
quick uh if anybody doesn't know what's
going on i'm sure you've heard about it
but
game stock okay game stop oh my god i
already [ __ ] it up
so gamestop uh was this brick and mortar
uh video game
store retail store that a lot of us went
to when we were younger buy video games
you buy some magazines etc you could
return video games they
never gave you anything for the video
game you buy it [ __ ] embarrassing it
was 50
video game you got three dollars and you
took that [ __ ] and they looked at you
like yeah you're gonna take it [ __ ]
yeah they really did they did yeah they
really did like dove when he's
negotiating your apartment
she killed us i don't know who
was offended by that no we suffered
together on that one all right fine we
suffered together
point is uh
they were uh looking like they were
gonna go out of business obviously in
the future they most likely are because
people aren't buying video games in the
same way that they used to buy in the
past
so there are these hedge funds hedge
funds are these uh conglomerates of uh
uh invested capital so there are these
invest there are these people who manage
billions and sometimes trillions of
dollars of wealthy people's money and
they
throw it at specific things and looking
to make huge margins on their
investments
right so it's not as safe as the average
maybe retail investor who just invests
in you know the
the dow or the vanguard account s p this
kind of nasdaq or whatever
um and one of the things they do is
short a stock so
shorting a stock is essentially um we
were doing this example like
with sneakers but basically you borrow
you bet on the stock going down
and the way you bet on a stock going
down is you borrow the stock
you then sell it to somebody else at the
price it's currently at
and then you ideally pay for that stock
from the person that you borrowed it
from at a new
lower price so you can make profit so
that you can make the difference of the
profit and what a lot of times these
hedge funds do
is they actually drive down the value of
that stock
yeah so with gamestop or maybe something
else
they would say hey this company's going
out of business it's about to bust they
get their friends in the media to also
say those things
and they get this entire frenzy going of
people who are selling that stock
right and then it tanks the stock and
ideally the company goes belly up
right it goes out of business and they
never even have to pay back
100 profit exactly remember yeah yeah go
what do the companies get out of it by
loaning the stock out
so it's not the company that's loaning
it that stock exists so for example i
could just own some gamestop
stock right so then let's say for
example right
i'm letting you borrow my gamestop stock
right okay and you go i'd like to borrow
it
knowing that you're gonna go sell it and
i go fine but you gotta pay me back in a
month
okay or two weeks so whatever we side
that window are they borrowing from
um i i think it's the same way as when
you buy stock on the internet
anyway like when you buy like some
shares of silver or whatever like you're
just and i think you also get paid a fee
if you are the lendy
you are person who lends or the lender
and you get a little fee while that
person is borrowing and the longer
that you don't pay for that stock
remember you borrowed it from me and
you're paying a fee it's like
hold on to it exactly and the longer you
don't pay me
the more you got to pay [ __ ] is a vig
exactly so
eventually what happens is you have this
wall street bets right you have this
reddit community that goes oh my god
gamestop they're trying to short to
oblivion they're trying to destroy this
company and take credit so it's a bunch
of [ __ ] dorks who love game stuff
probably
sure exactly they spent their childhood
there yeah shout outs to reddit but they
spent their childhood there and really
you know they they
understand that reddit employees not
ready gamestop employs 14
000 people and they see a [ __ ] greedy
parasitic hedge fund trying to make all
14 000 of those people unemployed
for their own personal game it's
absolutely disgusting yeah okay
shout out to everybody in that reddit
community right real talk
honestly like like that [ __ ] is noble
like that [ __ ] is brave
like i i love that [ __ ] no i hold the
line hold it yeah hold that [ __ ] line
talk about me bro i'm a person let's go
a partial owner in gamestop oops
okay so um basically what they did is
they saw that
gamestop was incredibly overshorted so
matter of fact
more of their stock was shorted than
existed
that's how shorted the stock was so
they're like oh my god these pieces [ __ ]
parasite hedge fund douchebags
are trying to drive this stock into the
ground so they can get all that [ __ ]
profit off the short
we're not having it let's band together
and let's start buying up the gamestop
stock it's really hard to say buying up
gme we'll call it
buying up gme and they'll drive the
price up they won't be able to make any
money on the short
and if we can keep on driving it up
they're going to lose money and have to
pay that
vig that interest they were talking
about and then they might lose so much
money they'll just have to buy the stock
itself
and they'll lose tons of money exactly
and when you have to buy the stock
itself
what happens when you buy stock price
goes up price goes up it's called a
short squeeze
so they short squeeze gme they short
squeeze gamestop
right and the price kept on going up
there's other things that also helped it
going up and we can get into that
and uh the app that a lot of these
people are using to buy was on
robin hood right robin hood is this app
the whole idea of the app is steal from
the rich gift to
give to the poor obviously robin hood
and what happened with robin hood is
they
uh stopped allowing people to buy the
stock and only allowed them to sell it
cox cox 100
i used i used robinhood that day that
they stopped it in the morning you
couldn't even log on to your account
isn't that crazy so about an hour i
couldn't even get to
and that's [ __ ] up because this is
your money yeah it's not like this is a
video game you're playing this is your
actual money you're like yo fam don't
[ __ ] with my money this is a very
different situation when you're messing
with people's hard-earned cash here
right
and the reason why this gets a little
conspiratorial is the way that robin
hood makes money
is that it shares the investors data
investors are you guys
right myself included our data with
hedge funds so all of our date of our
investments it shares with hedge funds
and they get it before the general
public get it and that's how hedge funds
can beat us on all the trades because
they know what the [ __ ] we're doing
before the average people do
you